Olá, boa noite.
Boa noite.
Nós estamos entrevistando esta semana os candidatos à presidência da República nas eleições 2026.
Foram convidados os seis candidatos mais bem colocados na pesquisa Quest de 14 de agosto.
A ordem das entrevistas foi decidida num sorteio com a presença de representantes das campanhas.
Hoje, então, nós recebemos aqui no estúdio o candidato Renan Santos, do Missão.
Amanhã será a vez de Luiz Inácio Lula da Silva, do PT.
Na sexta, Flávio Bolsonaro, do PL.
E no sábado, Augusto Cury, do Avante.
Nós já entrevistamos Romeu Zema, do Novo, e Ronaldo Caiado, do PSD.
Cada entrevista vai ter 40 minutos de duração com dois blocos e as considerações finais dos candidatos.
Vamos começar, então, relembrando a trajetória política de Renan Santos.
Renan Santos tem 42 anos.
Nasceu no bairro da Moca, em São Paulo.
Cursou o direito na USP.
Não concluiu a faculdade porque decidiu trabalhar com o pai e o irmão num escritório de recuperação de empresas.
Ele foi um dos fundadores do movimento Brasil Livre, em 2014.
Nas eleições de 2018, o MBL elegeu dois deputados, um federal e um estadual.
Integrantes do movimento decidiram, em 2023, criar um partido, o Missão.
E conseguiram um registro no TSE ano passado, depois de reunir quase 590 mil assinaturas.
Nas eleições deste ano, Renan Santos concorre à presidência.
Tem como candidato a vice, Haroldo Medina, do mesmo partido.
Candidato Renan Santos, boa noite. Obrigada pela sua presença.
Boa noite.
Boa noite, candidato.
Agradeço. Uma honra estar aqui com vocês.
Posso mandar um beijo para minha mãe e para minha sobrinha Angelina.
Titio está aqui, Angelina. Tamo junto.
O tempo da entrevista começa a contar a partir de agora.
Candidato, ao anunciar a candidatura no evento do seu partido,
o senhor declarou uma prioridade na área da defesa.
Desenvolver uma bomba atômica no Brasil.
O senhor, em entrevistas, foi categórico.
Disse que é obrigatório que o Brasil esteja armado e tenha bomba atômica.
Candidato, o mundo enfrenta as consequências graves, severas, da guerra no Oriente Médio.
Os Estados Unidos e Israel atacaram o Irã com a justificativa de que o país desenvolvia um arsenal nuclear.
Um momento de muita incerteza militar, política, econômica.
Por que motivo, então, o Brasil deveria, nesse momento, enveredar para uma corrida nuclear, na sua opinião?
Bom, excelente pergunta.
O mundo está passando por uma mudança muito grande, como a Renata descreveu.
O mundo está vivendo o fim do pacto pós-45, pós a Segunda Guerra Mundial,
quando os Estados Unidos disputavam primeiro com a União Soviética, quem mandava no mundo,
e depois os Estados Unidos, após a queda do Muro de Berlim, se tornaram a grande potência global.
Hoje, entretanto, os Estados Unidos vê a ascensão da China, uma outra superpotência,
que vai formando novos blocos.
O BRICS é um deles.
O Brasil acabou se alinhando através do PT ao bloco do BRICS.
E essas duas forças começam a se degladear em cenário internacional.
Primeiro, em guerras em que eles não participam diretamente.
Um exemplo é Rússia versus Ucrânia, outra Israel versus Irã.
E o Brasil começa a ver que está sujeito, de uma maneira passiva, submissa, como um agente menor, a essas disputas.
No futuro, se o Brasil quiser ser uma das cinco maiores nações do mundo
que se presta a sentar na mesa com Estados Unidos, Índia, Rússia e China,
ele vai precisar ter soberania sobre seu próprio território, soberania militar
e vai ter que discutir ter bombas atômicas.
Dentre as principais nações do mundo, esse aqui é um ponto bem importante,
que tem muito território, muita população e grande economia,
e a gente blocar União Europeia, Rússia, Índia, Estados Unidos, China e Brasil,
essas são as maiores nações, a União que não dispõe de armas nucleares é o Brasil.
Eu não acho que o Brasil dispõe de condições, nos próximos dez anos, de ter armas nucleares.
Nem tem condição de fazer ainda a pesquisa e desenvolver isso.
Mas o Brasil tem que iniciar um processo de recuperação de soberania, de pesquisa,
para ele poder sentar à mesa e discutir com o mundo.
O Brasil quer sentar no Conselho de Segurança da ONU e o Brasil tem que ter condições de ter uma arma atômica.
Até porque, pelas razões que foram levantadas, Renata,
o mundo vai olhar para o Brasil de maneira muito cheia de cobiça.
O Brasil possui recursos naturais, recursos alimentares, energia, terras raras
e, portanto, o mundo não vai ver o Brasil de maneira passiva.
Você sabe que a Constituição brasileira determina que a atividade nuclear em território nacional
só é admitido para fins pacíficos.
Em outubro do ano passado, o deputado do seu partido, Kim Kataguiri,
ele protocolou no Congresso uma proposta para alterar esse artigo da Constituição
e autorizar o Brasil a ter armas nucleares.
Eu queria saber, na sua avaliação, como é que reagiriam os países da América do Sul,
os Estados Unidos?
Isso não tensionaria ainda mais a relação com o governo americano?
Definitivamente, se eu imaginar que vou tensionar a relação com os Estados Unidos
impondo ao mundo, olha, o Brasil terá uma arma atômica agora?
Sim, o Brasil não estará em uma posição de exigir nada dos Estados Unidos,
nem da China, porque o Brasil está fraco.
O que eu vejo é que o Brasil tem que fazer uma construção de soberania.
A construção de soberania passa em reaver o respeito internacional pelo Brasil.
O Brasil hoje é um vassalo da China, de acordo com a ação política do Lula,
no cenário global.
Onde há uma briga internacional envolvendo o interesse chinês,
o Lula se pronuncia favoravelmente à China.
Basta ver o conflito de Israel com o Irã,
em que o Lula sai se pronunciando se o Brasil tem nenhum ganho
a favor do Irã ou a favor, por exemplo, da causa palestina.
Mas mesmo que o senhor demorasse para desenvolver essa arma nuclear,
essa intenção, esse começo mudando a Constituição brasileira,
o senhor não veria problemas com relação aos outros países?
Não, não, de maneira alguma.
Os Estados Unidos da América, ele vai ter que sentar com o Brasil,
a partir de agora, para a questão das terras raras,
para negociar a própria soberania americana em parceria com o Brasil.
Os Estados Unidos, a título de comparação para todo mundo entender,
os Estados Unidos para fazer um avião F-35,
que é o principal jato deles,
precisa de meia tonelada de terra rara.
Os Estados Unidos não dispõem nem das terras raras no seu território,
nem da extração, nem do processamento.
Ele precisa comprar da China, que é o seu maior rival.
Quem é o país que dispõe das segundas maiores reservas globais de terras raras?
É justamente o Brasil.
Os Estados Unidos vão ter que sentar com o Brasil
para ter a própria soberania militar nas próximas décadas.
Isso nos coloca numa posição muito interessante
para negociar com os Estados Unidos a construção de uma soberania regional.
Mas sobre negociação mesmo, por exemplo, teria que convencer a Argentina,
porque a base do acordo que fundou o Mercosul, por exemplo,
estabelece que Brasil e a Argentina devem renunciar a armas nucleares.
O senhor quebraria esse acordo e apostar numa bomba atômica
é a melhor maneira de negociar com a Argentina?
Eu acho, no médio e longo prazo, sim.
A não ser que o Brasil queira abdicar de ser uma potência.
Eu vejo o Brasil como uma das cinco maiores nações do mundo nos próximos 30 anos.
E uma nação que será uma das mais importantes do mundo nos próximos 30 anos
precisa ter armas nucleares.
Nós precisamos fazer uma retrospectiva de trás para frente.
O que nós seremos daqui 30 anos?
Daqui 30 anos nós temos que ser uma nação soberana,
que destrói o crime organizado, que lidera a América do Sul
e que vai ter força para negociar com seus vizinhos,
para estabelecer, olha, se nós vamos liderar junto com nossos vizinhos,
o nosso continente, para poder negociar em bloco, por exemplo,
com os Estados Unidos ou China, nós vamos precisar ter força militar.
Nós vamos precisar juntos trabalhar para a desconstrução
dessa indústria do crime organizado que toma o nosso continente.
E nesse sentido, sim, vamos ter que discutir a construção de armas nucleares.
Isso é passo de uma construção de uma nação soberana.
Eu volto a repetir.
Se o Brasil quiser ser uma nação importante nos próximos 30 anos,
o Brasil precisa ser uma nação poderosa.
Se o Brasil não quiser ser poderoso,
o Brasil vai ser submisso a projetos internacionais.
Assim como o Brasil vem sendo submisso.
Agora, candidato, uma decisão dessa magnitude,
ela não depende apenas de uma declaração de intenção.
E o programa do senhor não traz detalhes em relação a isso.
Então, eu pergunto ao senhor,
em que estudo científico, técnico, o senhor se baseia
para defender que o país deve desenvolver uma bomba atômica?
Qual a autoria dessa pesquisa, desse estudo?
E também, para concluir, de que maneira o senhor implantaria isso?
Eu não preciso de um estudo científico para determinar
que uma nação tem que ter força política
para se proteger de outras nações.
Eu posso trazer apenas dados da realidade.
A realidade é muito clara.
As nações mais poderosas do mundo dispõem de armas nucleares.
E elas se fazem respeitadas por causa disso.
A sua ideia é retirar o Brasil do Tratado de Não Coliferação de Armas?
Necessariamente, e no momento certo.
Apenas um país fez isso até agora, desde a Coreia do Norte.
Sim, mas pelo menos a Coreia do Norte,
por mais que seja um regime que eu considero opressivo
e que eu não o respeite,
pelo menos ele é respeitado internacionalmente
de maneira que a Venezuela não foi.
Ter armas nucleares é uma forma de defender a sua própria soberania.
O Brasil tem um dos maiores territórios do mundo.
O Brasil tem recursos naturais infindáveis.
Se a gente quiser ser o eterno Zé Carioca no mundo,
personagem engraçado em que os gringos vêm aqui para fazer festa
e que a gente exporta matéria-prima e recebe produto pronto,
tudo bem, não fazemos armas nucleares,
aceitamos nossa posição submissa.
Agora, se a gente quiser ser uma nação séria e respeitada,
nos próximos 30 anos nós vamos ter armas nucleares,
não para ficar arrumando briga,
mas ter poder de dissuasão,
para as nossas riquezas serem respeitadas.
Se os Estados Unidos da América,
que são uma nação hoje mais poderosa do mundo,
não fizeram a lição de casa,
deixaram a China ficar com todo o processamento
de terra rara do mundo nesse instante
e ver de maneira cobiçosa o Brasil,
nós vamos ter que olhar para os americanos e entender.
Se nós não tivermos meios de se defender,
o que nós vamos fazer?
Ora, nós vamos ter que reconstruir
uma rede de alianças internacionais
no mundo que vai se reconfigurar.
Isso é muito importante.
É que, Sérgio, eu preciso terminar isso aqui.
O mundo vai mudar muito.
O mundo vai se reconfigurar.
Se nós não reconstruímos essa rede
e o Brasil se colocar de maneira soberana
nesse mundo em conflito,
o Brasil vai ser vítima desse novo mundo que vem aí.
A ordem mundial pacífica acabou.
As guerras escritas pela NATO estão acontecendo.
E o Brasil vai ter que ser capaz
de se defender nas próximas décadas.
Na segurança pública, o senhor tem defendido
recorrer a estados de defesa, GLO e intervenções federais.
A promessa do senhor é, em um ano,
recuperar todos os territórios dominados
pelo crime organizado, facções criminosas,
no Brasil, ou seja, em todo o país.
Essa promessa, portanto, já foi feita pelo senhor.
Eu quero lembrar o caso aqui do Rio de Janeiro.
Em 2018, o Rio ficou sob intervenção federal,
durou 10 meses e meio.
O custo dessa intervenção foi de 1 bilhão e 200 milhões de reais.
E de lá para cá, o crime organizado expandiu ainda mais
a dominação sobre territórios do Estado.
Então, eu pergunto ao senhor o que permite ao senhor
dizer que é possível implantar esse seu plano
ao mesmo tempo em todo o país e nesse prazo de um ano?
Grande pergunta, César.
Vamos lá.
O Brasil vive uma guerra.
É uma guerra que foi declarada unilateralmente.
O crime organizado está em guerra com você,
que está nos assistindo,
e você fica considerando, vamos dizer,
que a tua vida é ser refém.
Se você mora numa favela, o crime organizado
manda em você, pode te desalojar da tua casa,
pode, eventualmente, se interessar de maneira sexual
pela tua filha e você não tem como se defender.
A vida no país que está em guerra
é uma vida triste.
Hoje, quase 40 milhões de brasileiros
vivem direta ou indiretamente
sob a influência do crime organizado.
Portanto, o que eu defendo é a criação
e a declaração de uma guerra contra o crime organizado.
É a aceitação de uma realidade que já é verdadeira para os brasileiros.
Precisamos de uma guerra contra eles.
Esse é o primeiro ponto.
Vou voltar um pouco no tempo para te responder.
Antes da GLO do Temer,
nós tivemos as UPPs aqui no Rio de Janeiro,
que foram uma outra tentativa de entrar em áreas
tomadas pelo crime organizado,
que no início obtiveram sucesso com as operações do BOPE
e depois não deram certo.
Por quê?
Porque o Brasil não fez um arcabouço legal
para permitir a continuidade desse processo.
Pois é, sobre esse arcabouço legal,
o seu plano fala em decretar sucessivos estados de defesa,
mas não explica que sequência seria essa,
porque a Constituição autoriza 30 dias,
prorrogável por mais 30 dias, uma única vez.
O senhor vai propor uma mudança na Constituição para isso?
É que não é isso o arcabouço legal.
O arcabouço legal é...
Nós precisamos...
E já passou um pedaço disso agora, no ano passado,
que foi essa legislação que converte as facções criminosas
em entes especiais similares a organizações terroristas
que vão ter um tratamento jurídico diferente.
Agora, nós temos que alterar também as leis de execuções penais,
o Código de Processo Penal e o aumento de penas,
especialmente para crimes violentos cometidos com armas,
que é basicamente uma parte dos crimes que assolam a vida dos brasileiros.
Quando houve a experiência dos UPPs no Rio de Janeiro,
por mais que eles tenham derrotado inicialmente o crime organizado
e feito a ocupação nas favelas,
não houve a posteriori a mudança nas leis
que permitiam que o enfrentamento continuasse com sucesso.
Esse é o problema.
O governo nosso tem que passar essas leis
e essas medidas têm que passar antes de entrar com o Estado de Defesa.
Agora, candidato...
Espera, César, que isso é muito importante,
é para responder a tua pergunta.
Se eu altero essa legislação
e aí eu entro com as medidas ligadas ao Estado de Defesa,
eu consigo fazer a ocupação,
a desconstrução do espaço político
das facções criminosas
e aí sim, com um regime diferenciado para os criminosos,
porque a legislação, dentro desse princípio
que eu chamo de direito penal do inimigo...
Mas, candidato, no Rio de Janeiro não deu certo.
Então, assim, se a gente pegar...
Como eu disse, não havia certo abuso, César.
Pegar um pouco da história recente, olha só.
Eu trouxe os números aqui da intervenção feita no Complexo da Maré.
O senhor deve se lembrar,
abril de 2014 ela começou,
foi até junho de 2015.
Ou seja, um ano e três meses de ocupação.
23 mil militares no Complexo da Maré.
Custou mais de 500 milhões de reais na época.
11 anos depois,
o Complexo da Maré continua dominado pelas mesmas facções.
Então, o que eu pergunto ao senhor é
o que o senhor faria de diferente?
E claro que, para o eleitor,
é muito importante saber também
se existe viabilidade econômica, financeira.
Quanto é que custaria fazer isso
se não deu certo no Rio,
no Brasil todo, como o senhor promete,
em um ano,
recuperar todas as áreas dominadas por facções?
De maneira muito clara, como eu falei,
se você não altera a legislação penal
e a lei de execuções penais,
de nada de anta fazer a prisão de um traficante
que vai ser solto logo depois.
Não há, hoje,
meios de você manter uma pessoa
que comete um crime sendo membro de uma facção
presa por tanto tempo.
A mudança da legislação é essencial.
A legislação que eu chamo de direito penal do inimigo,
e isso explicando para quem está nos ouvindo,
é uma legislação que trata
uma pessoa que é diferente de um cidadão comum,
ou seja, um traficante, um membro de uma facção,
como um ente anômalo.
Ou seja, a legislação vai ser muito dura,
o direito vai ser mais rápido com ele,
nós vamos poder atingir ele de maneira mais veloz,
ou seja, o Estado vai poder montar operações,
a tutela antecipada das operações vai acontecer.
Ou seja, o Estado é muito veloz,
e o uso da velocidade,
que é a ideia de direito de terceira velocidade,
o uso dessa velocidade para buscar o inimigo,
o uso de operações mais velozes,
o uso de penas maiores,
a construção de mais presídios,
e isso vai permitir que, depois da ocupação,
a facção seja destruída,
que é o que precisamos fazer.
A facção precisa ser...
Sobre essas leis mais duras,
mas é sobre isso que o senhor...
É que, Renata, eu não tenho que terminar esse ponto dele,
porque senão eu não vou terminar o argumento.
Eu tenho uma pergunta para fazer sobre esse argumento.
Ele perguntou a questão financeira.
Então, primeiro é,
é óbvio que dá para você fazer a recuperação territorial,
e é óbvio que o Estado não pode permitir
o retorno das facções.
E, dois, não há outro meio além de reocupar o território.
Ou seja, você vai ter que aceitar que você vai fazer a guerra.
Senão a gente vai ficar aceitando que vão vir aqui perto da Globo,
não sei se foi aqui, foi no Jardim Botânico,
o pessoal vai ficar jogando bomba ali na frente,
como aconteceu essa semana.
A gente não vai poder ficar aceitando
que o crime organizado tem,
nos bairros e favelas, fortalezas.
A guerra é uma necessidade.
O que altera do que aconteceu
nesses exemplos que você deu,
que são bons exemplos,
é haverá uma nova legislação especial
tratando o membro da facção como um ente anônomo.
Quanto custaria?
Foi a pergunta do Trale.
Vou dar um exemplo só na parte de presídio.
Quanto custaria?
Só na parte de presídio, 6 bilhões de reais
nós precisamos fazer para abrir vagas,
para construir 10 presídios,
cada um de 30 a 40 mil vagas.
Esse processo precisa se iniciar desde já.
Uma operação dessas,
para você tocar no estado do Rio de Janeiro,
coisa de 5 bilhões estimado por ano,
numa operação,
só para você sustentar não só a base militar,
e depois a operação das polícias.
E depois as operações não vão ser demoradas,
as operações precisam ser rápidas.
Primeiro você faz a ocupação junto com as forças policiais,
e não serão forças militares com o Exército.
O Exército vai servir como força auxiliar.
Quem vai organizar as operações são as forças policiais.
São forças policiais.
O Exército atua de maneira auxiliar.
E o grande custo que você tem nessas operações
é o custo ligado à atividade dos militares,
das Forças Armadas,
que são custosos.
O nosso modelo,
que está descrito no nosso livro,
ele utiliza e empodera as forças policiais.
Inclusive, ele não precisa, em diversos estados,
entrar com um estado de defesa.
Vou dar um exemplo.
Sobre isso, antes do seu exemplo,
eu gostaria de entender que o senhor falou em penas mais duras,
porque durante a sua pré-campanha,
o senhor exaltou e disse que se inspirava
na política do presidente de El Salvador,
Naebi Bukele.
O governo dele reduziu os índices de criminalidade,
mas usando medidas de exceção.
Recentemente, o senhor passou a dizer
eu não sou Bukele,
mas manteve pontos centrais da política dele,
como, por exemplo,
o fim da prosunção da inocência
para pessoas que foram classificadas como inimigas da nação.
Quem é que vai definir quem é um inimigo da nação?
E como é que o senhor garantiria
que não haveria arbitrariedades
na classificação de uma pessoa que é inimiga da nação?
Renata, isso já acontece hoje.
Quando há uma investigação tocada por uma polícia
ou um Ministério Público
que demonstra que há uma formação de quadrilha,
que demonstra que há membros de uma facção como o PCC
tocando uma operação na Baixada Santista,
a autoridade policial determina isso.
Isso é uma determinação que já é feita,
isso já é bem tradicional.
Prisões sem mandato,
tortura e desaparecimentos,
violação do devido processo legal.
Eu vou fazer tortura?
Prisões arbitrárias.
Estou perguntando ao senhor.
Não.
Essas são as políticas do Bukele.
Eu gostaria de saber qual tortura.
Você poderia demonstrar o caso,
porque eu não tenho...
Ele suspendeu direitos,
promoveu detenções arbitrárias.
Vamos fazer então, Renata,
para a gente ser preciso.
Me dá o exemplo um a um
que eu digo se eu vou fazer
ou se ele mesmo fez.
Não, são denúncias graves
de violações lá em El Salvador.
Eu tenho que saber qual foi a denúncia,
porque eu acompanho o caso de El Salvador.
Suspensão de direitos, por exemplo,
como a presunção da inocência,
que o senhor acabou de dizer.
Sim.
E quem classificaria
quem é o inimigo da nossa...
As autoridades policiais...
Vou dar um exemplo.
Agora passou uma legislação
que trata membros de facções criminosas.
Autoridade policial.
As autoridades policiais,
o Ministério Público,
a Polícia Federal,
o processo investigativo.
E como evitar arbitrariedades
na classificação?
O devido processo legal.
O devido processo legal existe para isso.
Mas, Renata,
eu estou surpreso,
porque isso já acontece hoje.
Hoje existem investigações
que determinam que uma pessoa
é membro de uma facção
ou há uma influência
chamada Deolani.
Descobriram que a Deolani
ela era não apenas
uma influenciadora,
mas uma advogada ligada ao PCC.
Ora, a investigação pegou ela,
ela foi presa.
Isso é o básico,
isso já existe.
Candidato,
não há nenhuma novidade.
Declarações do senhor.
Mas é que esses pontos
sobre El Salvador,
muitos elementos
que foram adotados em El Salvador,
e de maneira muito similar
vão ser adotados por mim.
Por exemplo?
Lista.
Eu vou dar um exemplo
a ideia de enfrentamento
usando um regime especial,
aqui o Estado de Defesa,
em áreas dominadas pelo crime,
eu vou adotar.
Vai ter um regime de exceção
em favelas
para eu retomar a favela.
Julgamento coletivo de réus,
centenas de réus.
Prisões baseadas
em denúncia anônima.
O Brasil hoje existe
prisão baseada
em denúncia anônima.
Eu disse que denúncia existe.
A questão é,
não só em denúncia anônima.
Julgamento coletivo
de centenas de réus.
Vou dar um exemplo.
Denúncia anônima.
Hoje, se você fizer
uma denúncia anônima
de que uma pessoa
é membro de uma facção
e há um processo de investigação
que leve esse investigado
à cadeia
porque encontraram outras provas,
é tudo normal.
Isso existe na legislação brasileira.
Isso não é novidade.
Julgamento coletivo
de centenas de réus.
É um caso...
Você conhece esse caso?
É o Salvador.
É um caso...
Eu vou te narrar o caso.
É um caso de 456 pessoas,
lideranças de um movimento
chamado MS-13,
que é basicamente
a principal facção de El Salvador,
em que eles foram julgados
num modelo similar ao de Nuremberg
pelo assassinato
de 29 mil pessoas.
Ou seja,
eles foram corresponsabilizados
pela cadeia de comando
num modelo muito similar
ao julgamento de Nuremberg.
Creio que todos aqui
que rejeitam o Holocausto
creiam que o julgamento
de Nuremberg
foi um julgamento correto.
Turturas e desaparecimentos?
Não.
Não conheço
as torturas e desaparecimentos
que você está falando, Renata.
Eu acho que isso aí
é um clichê
que a mídia internacional
fala sobre o caso.
Candidato, em relação a declarações
em relação a declarações
do senhor.
Por favor.
É que eu preciso comentar
o ponto dela.
Tortura e desaparecimento
acontece todos os dias no Brasil.
O crime organizado
está torturando
e matando as pessoas diariamente.
Além das mortes
na casa das 40 mil pessoas
que acontecem todos os anos,
desaparecem outros milhares.
São corpos que não são encontrados.
Não era para institucionalizar isso, né?
Esse é o problema.
Já está institucionalizado.
Se você vai numa favela
em que não há Estado democrático de direito,
em que as pessoas
não dispõem de guia e direito,
as pessoas precisam ser libertas
e elas podem ser torturadas
nesses lugares.
Cabe ao Estado
recuperar essas áreas.
São todas denúncias
que vieram de famílias
de El Salvador.
São denúncias levantadas
pelo jornalismo profissional
fazendo reportagens
em El Salvador
e até mesmo
por parte de entidades
independentes
que fiscalizam
segurança pública
também em El Salvador.
Então, só para a gente
seguir aqui, por favor,
declarações do senhor.
Matar quem roubar
e fazer um banho de sangue.
O senhor diz que o senhor
não é o Bukele.
Mas então,
por que o senhor mantém
esse tom
defendido
pelo Naí Bukele?
Na última
segunda-feira,
um rapaz
chamado Eduardo
lá em São Paulo,
ele viu sua namorada
sendo assaltada
no meio da rua,
aparece o bandido,
ele tenta evitar o assalto.
O bandido
olha para o Eduardo,
puxa a arma,
tum,
dá um tiro na cabeça
do Eduardo.
A cabeça do Eduardo
explode
e o sangue
vaza na rua.
Houve um banho de sangue
na segunda-feira
de um inocente.
Eu acho que o sangue
que tem que jorrar
não é dele,
o sangue que tem que jorrar
é do bandido.
Eu acho que as pessoas
no Brasil,
e eu rodeio o Brasil
a pé e de carro
nos últimos meses todos,
as pessoas no Brasil
estão implorando
para que a gente faça justiça
contra essas figuras
terríveis,
esses demônios
que estão matando a gente.
E cabe ao presidente
da república
liderar as pessoas
nessa guerra.
Os brasileiros morrem
como se fosse bicho.
Ninguém liga,
ninguém sabe o nome.
A maior parte são meninos,
em geral,
negros,
que morrem nas favelas
e nas cidades mais pobres.
Pessoas são vítimas
de latrocínio diariamente.
Desde que a gente começou
esse programa,
no mínimo,
uma pessoa já foi assassinada
e, em geral,
vítima dessas facções criminosas.
Agora, candidato,
eu gostaria de abordar também
um tema importante.
Eu não respondo o César ainda.
Deixa eu só terminar.
Por favor, Renata.
Para que a gente possa abordar
vários temas.
Eu também quero.
Eu falo rápido
justamente para ajudar a abordar.
Falo do banho de sangue.
Pode não ser a palavra
mais bonita
para a pessoa
que está assistindo em casa,
mas é a única coisa
que eu posso fazer
como resposta
para alguém que está
com uma arma apontada
para uma pessoa.
Uma pessoa que aponta
uma arma para você
no meio da rua
para te cometer um assalto
é a pessoa que pode matar você
por latrocínio.
Ela se torna juiz da tua vida.
Ela se torna juiz
dos teus sonhos.
do teu futuro.
Ela não tem o direito
de se comportar
como juiz da tua vida.
Se um policial
estiver na tua frente,
e por isso que um slogan
de maneira automática
surgiu o meu respeito
na internet,
que era prender ou matou,
se um policial
estiver ali na frente,
ele tem que atirar
para matar nessa pessoa.
E eu falo isso
porque eu sou um pacifista,
nem sei atirar.
E esse tema
nem foi central para mim.
Agora, eu já tive minha mãe
alvo de sequestro relâmpago.
Todo mundo já no Brasil
passou por uma experiência traumática.
Todo mundo sabe
que tem um bandido
com a arma na cabeça
de um parente seu.
A gente não pode aceitar
mais ser refém dessas pessoas.
E o povo brasileiro
está pedindo uma guerra.
É uma guerra o brasileiro quer.
Em 2022,
o senhor e um dos principais
nomes do seu partido,
o Missão,
um aliado seu e amigo
Arthur Duval,
estiveram juntos na Ucrânia
e vieram a público áudios
em que Duval
fez declarações
machistas
sobre mulheres ucranianas.
Ele disse o seguinte,
abre aspas,
elas são fáceis
porque são pobres.
Essas falas tiveram
uma forte repercussão,
levaram até a perda
do mandato,
a cassação do mandato dele.
E numa live
no dia 9 de março de 22,
o senhor disse
que estava ao lado dele
quando ele fez
essas declarações.
Gostaria de saber
como é que o senhor
avalia elas hoje.
Foram declarações ruins.
Vamos contextualizar.
Eu não ouvi ele
quando ele emitiu o áudio.
Eu vi que ele estava
fazendo um áudio ali
com o celular na mão.
gostaria de ter evitado.
O áudio que ele mandou
em defesa dele
foi um áudio
em um ambiente privado
com amigos dele.
Não era nem dentro
do nosso grupo político.
E esse áudio vazou
e após vazar
ele sofreu as consequências
políticas dele.
O áudio é muito ruim.
se a pessoa ouve o áudio
a pessoa realmente
qualquer mulher
ou homem mesmo
fica
esse áudio não é adequado.
Dito isso
foi um áudio privado
no ambiente privado
e ele perdeu o mandato dele.
Ele sendo um deputado
estadual
muito combativo
na Lespe
não por conta do áudio em si.
Ele perdeu o mandato
porque ele era
basicamente de oposição
ao grupo político dominante
na Assembleia Legislativa
de São Paulo.
Dito isso
não foi um bom áudio
de maneira alguma.
candidato
92% dos filiados
do seu partido
são homens
muito acima
da média
dos outros partidos.
Episódios como esse
que a Renata relatou
aqui envolvendo o senhor
o Arthur Duval
não afastam as mulheres
do seu partido
ou missão?
De maneira alguma.
Em 2022
o ano que aconteceu
Por que então
92% de homens?
Vou te contar
uma história
que o Brasil
precisa saber
uma história muito triste.
O ano que aconteceu
isso com o Arthur
foi o ano que a gente tinha
na nossa academia
de formação
um mau número de mulheres
a proporção era 60 a 40.
No ano seguinte
às vésperas da eleição
para vereador
e prefeito em São Paulo
a nossa candidata principal
Amanda Vettorazo
que hoje é coordenadora
da minha campanha
ela foi
isso está na imprensa
isso é uma historinha
que eu estou contando
ela foi primeiro
alvo de uma série
de ataques de um stalker
que perseguiu ela
hoje o stalker está preso
ela teve o seu endereço
revelado
pessoas picharam a casa dela
um movimento de esquerda
que se diz
inclusive defensores das mulheres
e depois
a mãe dela
e a tia e a avó dela
foram sequestradas
meses depois
vários deepfakes
montagens foram feitas
dela pelada
e toda sorte de ataque
envolvendo a intimidade
dela foram feitas
o número de moças
que atuam politicamente
com a gente
depois de casos como esse
e outros casos
acontecem com lideranças nossas
eles se repetem
e se repetem
só que eles costumam ser
mais silenciados
pela mídia
do que casos que acontecem
no outro bloco
que é a esquerda
mas o seu plano de governo
por exemplo
não trata do combate
ao feminicídio
também não apresenta
políticas específicas
sobre homicídios
de crianças
violência sexual infantil
e abuso
só para informar
o telespectador
os números do fórum brasileiro
de segurança pública
mostram que só no ano passado
mais de 1500 mulheres
foram vítimas
de feminicídio
no Brasil
mais de 2000
crianças e jovens
foram mortas
vítimas da violência
o senhor não incluiu
políticas específicas
para enfrentar
esses problemas
por quê?
posso terminar o Sérgio
vou entrar
pergunta correlacionada
boa
a questão dessas mulheres
não é
das mulheres não entrarem
no partido
é porque é um medo
generalizado
nós elegemos uma vereadora
e eu preciso trazer
esse caso para o Brasil
aqui
é um palco privilegiado
para trazer
há uma vereadora
nossa eleita
na cidade de Chapada
Gaúcha
chamada Luana
essa moça foi alvo
da mesma natureza
de ataques da Amanda
a Câmara dos Vereadores
da cidade se reuniu
e estão caçando ela
por absolutamente nada
a violência política
de gênero
que acontece contra pessoas
não só do nosso grupo político
mas em geral da direita
é muito maior do que imagino
mas a gente fez um levantamento
nos sete maiores partidos brasileiros
46% de filiados
são mulheres
pois é
no Missão
8%
mas o Missão
é um partido novo
e o Missão é um partido
marcado por esse tipo
de perseguição às mulheres
a Amanda Vitorazo
passou por uma perseguição
que eu não conheço
nenhum outro grupo político
que tem uma mulher
que passa por perseguição similar
a perseguição que ela passa
é gigantesca
as meninas que fazem parte
da nossa academia de formação
tem medo de ser candidata
medo
medo de filiar
políticas específicas
sobre feminicídio
e sobre também
a violência contra as crianças
eu só vou chegar nesse ponto
porque uma coisa
não está correlacionada a outra
eu vou deixar isso primeiro
bem claro
segunda coisa
não há
como eu te disse
nem políticas específicas
do nosso livro
sobre homicídio
homicídio como um todo
sobre latrocínio
que é o tema que eu mais falo
porque a nossa política
de segurança
que está descrito
no nosso livro de propostas
ela é focada
acima de tudo
no combate
ao crime organizado
a guerra ao crime organizado
que nós debatemos bastante
aqui no começo do programa
a guerra ao crime organizado
ela pressupõe uma ação
do governo federal
alteração nas leis penais
alteração nas leis de execução penal
que vão pegar
de maneira extensiva
também
crimes que acontecem
contra mulheres
crianças
o ponto que é
muito importante
é a formulação
de políticas públicas
efetivas no combate
feminicídio
violência contra criança
e é uma correlação direta
o mesmo homem
que costuma ser abusivo
com a sua esposa
ou namorada
costuma ser abusivo
também com seus filhos
e o combate a isso
exige medidas específicas
exige medidas
que são adotadas
majoritariamente
por municípios e estados
porque nós respeitamos
o princípio federativo
um exemplo que nós
respeitamos o princípio federativo
é houve uma votação
recentemente
em que o governo Lula
queria avocar
para o governo federal
mais poderes
sobre a formulação
de políticas públicas
de segurança
nos estados
e nós votamos contra
porque quem tem que fazer
a formulação
das políticas públicas
e das ações
sobre feminicídio
e violência contra crianças
e violência como um todo
são os estados
e de maneira
subsidiar os municípios
eu vou
eu vou seguir aqui
porque esse tema
é bastante importante
o nosso plano de governo
é um plano articulado
ele não foi escrito
para o marqueteiro
porque se eu quiser escrever
um plano de governo
para o marqueteiro
eu botava todos esses casos
para ilustrar de maneira
marquetável
olha esse problema está aqui
esse problema está aqui
eu vendia
não
eu não vou fazer isso
porque o nosso plano
contém
quando a gente segue ele
mais para a terceira parte dele
que é a parte da lei
de responsabilidade gerencial
que é o meu grande legado
para o Brasil
ele estabelece a seguinte regra
prefeitos
e depois governadores
receberão mais recursos
desde que eles batam metas
dentre as metas de desempenho
que incluem
saúde
fornecimento de água
desempenho no IDEB
desempenho no SAEB
estão rankings ligados
a segurança
diminuição do número
de violência contra a mulher
então na casa 250 mil
todos os anos
isso só os reportados
casos de homicídio
casos de latrocínio
roubos e furtos
esses indicadores
que vão ser montados
pelo governo federal
e que vão servir
para você fiscalizar
a atuação dos municípios
eles vão basilar
a formulação
de políticas públicas
dos municípios
por exemplo
São Paulo
tem uma das
São Paulo capital
a cidade
tem uma das melhores
políticas de enfrentamento
a feminicídio
e violência contra a mulher
a Patrulha Maria da Penha
em São Paulo
está funcionando
e quem está
dentro do regime
da Patrulha Maria da Penha
não enfrentou
nenhum caso de feminicídio
mas a gente está falando
de políticas federais
mas o Traile tem uma
pergunta sobre um tema
importante
desculpa
esse tema é muito importante
a principal política federal
ela vai surgir baseada
em quem está executando
a política pública na ponta
que em geral é o município
ou o estado
porque não é o governo federal
que tem o poder de polícia
para executar isso
se tem um marido
que está batendo
na sua esposa
não é o governo federal
que vai colocar alguém
dentro da casa dele
em geral quem está mais próximo
é uma patrulha
envolvendo uma guarda municipal
numa cidade grande
ou uma patrulha rural
numa cidade distante
eu falo isso com preocupação
porque esse tema
é central para a gente
minha irmã quase morreu
por feminicídio na França
minha irmã foi alvo
de uma tentativa
assim de 18 B.O.s
que ela fez
contra um marido agressor
a lei francesa
ela é completamente vazia
a prefeitura de Paris
não fez nada
minha irmã teve que vir
com a filha dela para o Brasil
esse assunto é central
aqui em São Paulo
e isso é a coisa
eu estou falando aqui
tem um outro assunto
central
importante
aqui por favor
para a gente poder
dar continuidade
na entrevista
eu considero esse tema
fundamental
o senhor já declarou
que se eleito
vai descumprir decisões
do Supremo Tribunal Federal
que o senhor
considera ilegais
um presidente da república
assim como qualquer cidadão
se discordar de uma decisão
pode recorrer
exatamente
a justiça
então eu pergunto
ao senhor o seguinte
se como presidente
o senhor passar
a decidir
o que é que o senhor
vai respeitar da justiça
vai ignorar
descumprir
não aceitar
quem é que
determinaria
os limites do senhor
a lei
César Trale
há uma decisão
do STF
que diz o seguinte
decisão ilegal
não se cumpre
é uma decisão
do STF
inclusive
não estou nem falando
da própria constituição
César
recentemente
o Alexandre de Moraes
numa decisão
que eu atribuo
como grotesca
violou
uma cláusula pétrea
da constituição
quebrando o sigilo
de fonte
de jornalistas
lá no Maranhão
ele fez isso agora
jornalistas
do Brasil inteiro
protestaram
porque não existe
democracia
sem sigilo de fonte
não há como ter
imagina se revela
um sigilo de fonte
aqui da Rede Globo
quantas investigações
quantas matérias fundamentais
para manutenção
democracia
não tenham caído
ele derrubou
o sigilo de fonte
isso é cláusula pétrea
só para quem está entendendo
sigilo de fonte
tem o mesmo status
quanto por exemplo
pena de morte
então na mesma linha
o Alexandre de Moraes
podia por decreto
por um ali
da cabeça dele
mandar
por favor se execute
fulano de tal
por descumprimento
de uma regra
tem o mesmo peso
de eliminar o sigilo de fonte
não se deveria
por parte das autoridades
cumprir uma decisão
grotesca
que breca
que quebra
basicamente um princípio
constitucional basilar
não é que eu vou
eu preciso contextualizar
não é que eu falei
que vou sair desrespeitando
todas as decisões do STF
que isso é absurdo
o que eu avisei
num podcast
e depois eu repeti
lá na Globo News
numa ótima entrevista
com a Natuza
foi o seguinte
uma decisão
num caso específico
como por exemplo
eu estou fazendo uma operação
para libertar a população
de uma favela
aqui no Rio de Janeiro
aí no meio dessa operação
quando a própria população
está denunciando casos
de violência que aconteceu
contra elas
vem uma decisão monocrática
do STF
absolutamente legal
dado que eu estarei cumprindo
o devido processo legislativo
devido processo legal
naquela operação
e aí eles mandam
pera pera
mas candidato
por favor
se nós
se eu não te der esse exemplo
eu não vou conseguir
um senador
um prefeito
um governador
poderiam fazer a mesma coisa
ou isso seria uma prerrogativa
só do senhor
caso eleito
presidente da república
não poderiam
poderiam fazer
porque decisão
na verdade qualquer cidadão
diante de uma decisão ilegal
ele pode não cumprir
na verdade ele tem um dever
de não cumprir
decisão ilegal
não se cumpre
se você cumpre
vier com uma decisão ilegal
que faça as pessoas
correm um risco muito grande
você não pode cumprir
uma decisão ilegal
pode acabar com a vida
de uma pessoa
o exemplo que eu estava dando
foi num podcast
do Rodrigo Pimentel
aqui no Rio de Janeiro
foi
se eu estou no meio
de uma operação policial
e vem uma decisão monocrática
e eu cumpri todos os ritos formais
previstos na nossa constituição
e que são basilares
para a nossa democracia
se vem uma decisão monocrática
falando
não
pare tudo
e isso vai colocar em risco
a vida dos moradores
daquela favela
eu não vou cumprir
mas não é que eu vou cumprir
da minha cabeça
porque eu sou apenas eu
eu vou via AGU
a advocacia da Geraldo Anião
vou pedir um parecer
olha
é uma decisão ilegal
ok eu não vou cumprir
e vou por favor
recorrer ao STF
só que o cumprimento disso
pode eventualmente
gerar perdas
e morte para muitas pessoas
eu não vou colocar
a vida das pessoas em risco
candidato
nós vamos agora
fazer um rápido intervalo
e daqui a pouco
voltamos com outros temas
nessa entrevista
com o candidato
à presidência da república
Renan Santos
do partido Missão
a gente volta já já
estamos de volta
com a entrevista
com o candidato
Renan Santos
candidato
eu gostaria de falar
sobre direito ao voto
Orlando Lima
um dos principais colaboradores
do seu plano de governo
disse o seguinte
eu peço licença
aqui para abrir aspas
pessoas que não tem propriedade
que recebem auxílio do governo
essas pessoas
tinham que ter apenas
os direitos básicos
você não teria direito
por exemplo
ao voto
o senhor concorda
com essa ideia
se eleito
o senhor promoveria
alguma medida
para restringir o direito
a voto
do cidadão
não
isso é a opinião dele
eu nem sabia da opinião
mas se ele falou isso
é a opinião dele
e por que Orlando Lima
tem uma participação
tão destacada
no seu programa de governo
porque ele é um grande pesquisador
mesmo com declarações
como essa
sugerindo restrição
ao direito
ao voto
do cidadão
a pessoa pode dar
uma declaração infeliz
e fazer uma pesquisa
sobre história
brilhante
eu conheço grandes
pesquisadores
grandes jornalistas
que às vezes
dão declarações ruins
o planejamento
do livro amarelo
surgiu sobretudo
pelas ideias
de colaboradores
como Orlando Silva
foram mais de 200 colaboradores
Orlando Lima
perdão
Orlando Silva
do PCdoB
Orlando Lima
foram mais de 200 pessoas
que trabalharam
na elaboração do livro
são pesquisadores
ao redor do Brasil
inclusive de fora do Brasil
que participaram
desse projeto
o Orlando
é um deles
é um dos mais importantes
mas isso não determina
que uma declaração ruim dele
vai interferir nesse processo
que é colaborativo
nós temos como princípio
o Basilar
a defesa do Estado Democrático
de Direito
eu estudei na faculdade de Direito
mais antiga do Brasil
eu faço e pratico
democracia
desde os meus 18 anos de idade
quando eu comecei
eu montei meu primeiro partido
acadêmico
na faculdade de Direito da USP
no Largo São Francisco
participei da elaboração
da alteração do estatuto
do centro acadêmico
criei o movimento
Brasil Livre
lutei contra movimentos
golpistas
que haviam
nas manifestações
pelo impeachment da Dilma
gente que depois
já estava em 2022
participando de atos
que vocês mesmos
cobriram bastante
nós temos
o nosso pendor democrático
sempre foi gigantesco
o senhor respondeu a pergunta
agora vamos falar de economia
porque a dívida pública
a gente sabe está hoje
em 82% do PIB
e se eleito
o senhor promete cortar
1 trilhão
e 100 bilhões de reais
para que percentual do PIB
o senhor se compromete
a trazer essa dívida
e como o senhor
vai chegar até ela
claro
a beleza do corte
do corte de gastos
é porque a trajetória da dívida
não necessariamente
ela caia
mas ela se mantém estável
existem nações
ela está em trajetória de ar
exato
mas as medidas
que nós vamos adotar
no mínimo
vão deixar ela estável
como?
com corte de gastos
e aumento de PIB
existe uma relação
dívida PIB
o PIB do Brasil
está próximo dos 12 trilhões
a dívida próxima dos 10 trilhões
hoje ela está acelerando
velozmente
nós precisamos cortar
a velocidade
de aceleração dela
ela acelera através
das indexações
e vinculações
que são um tema
muito complicado
para eu explicar
para as pessoas aqui
se eu tiver um minutinho
talvez esse tema
é bem importante
basicamente
para quem está assistindo
as medidas que o Palmeiras
e o Flamengo
adotaram
para salvar esses times
o Palmeiras aqui
para o pessoal assistir
continuem na Globo assistindo
tem que ser adotados
pelo Brasil
para sobreviver
quem não adotou
as medidas
do São Paulo
Corinthians
e outros times
quebraram
o Brasil está tomando
as medidas
para administrar
suas contas públicas
igualzinho
a dos grandes times
de futebol brasileiro
que não fizeram ajuntes
como Vasco
como São Paulo
Corinthians
então o senhor propõe
desindexar
benefícios do salário
desvinculações
do piso
da educação
e da saúde
até porque hoje
eles estão irracionais
e estão quebrando
pequenos municípios
tem municípios
do interior do Rio Grande do Sul
que a população envelheceu
não está nascendo gente
então eles precisam
de mais gasto com saúde
e menos gasto com educação
as vinculações
fazem que eles
sejam obrigados
a gastar com educação
mesmo quase não tendo
crianças novas
lugares como Mato Grosso
que tem migração interna
muito grande
eles precisam
de maiores gastos
em educação
essa liberdade
precisa ser gerada
hoje quando a liberdade
não é gerada
você tem basicamente
um gasto ineficiente
pouco inteligente
de dinheiro
esse é o problema
da vinculação
as indexações
as vinculações
somadas a uma nova
reforma da Previdência
e avisando você
eu não sou estelionatário
eleitoral como outros
candidatos que vão vir aqui
e falar que não precisa
vamos precisar fazer
outra reforma da Previdência
senão vai quebrar
e em três anos
você não tem aposentadoria
eu vou deixar claro
porque eu não sou
populista fiscal aqui
um monte de gente
vai ficar mentindo
que não vai precisar
de fazer reforma
e vai precisar fazer reforma
pois bem
todas essas medidas
vão evitar aceleração
e o resto é corte gastos
que nós vamos fazer
só que a beleza
dos cortes gastos
é que eles serão vinculados
aí sim a investimento
em infraestrutura
que é uma coisa
que o Brasil está precisando
para poder voltar a crescer
candidato
outro tema que está tendo
muito impacto hoje
na vida das pessoas
se chama meio ambiente
já tem muito tempo
que o planeta
vem enfrentando
efeitos de fenômenos
climáticos extremos
cientistas reforçando
o alerta cada vez mais
para que as cidades
se preparem
mitiguem
façam investimentos
em prevenção
preparem as populações
salvem as pessoas
de desastres climáticos
agora o programa do senhor
não apresenta
uma política estruturada
de adaptação
a essas mudanças climáticas
e nem de prevenção
a esses desastres
que tem se repetido
de forma muito espantosa
para todos nós
por que que uma emergência
dessa dimensão
não recebeu
uma política específica
no seu programa de governo
porque as políticas específicas
já existem nos planos
de não os planos
de governo
mas nas metas
de infraestrutura
de todos os estados
e municípios
que estão em regiões problemáticas
por exemplo
o Rio Grande do Sul
já tinha todas as manutenções
a serem feitas
no seu sistema de comportas
para evitar o que aconteceu
com aquelas chuvas
todo mundo sabia
o que precisava ser feito
em juízo de fora
para evitar aquele deslize
todo mundo sabia
o que precisava ser feito
em Angra
ou na Baixada Santista
ou no litoral de São Paulo
para evitar os desastres
que houveram
o problema é que não há dinheiro
para investimento
em infraestrutura
os planos inclusive
já existem
a coisa mais desesperadora
é os planos
nos estados e municípios
existem
não tem o dinheiro
e por que não tem o dinheiro?
pela mesma pergunta
muito bem feita
pela Renata
porque não há capacidade
do estado
em reduzir seus gastos
obrigatórios
reduzir despesas
cortar mamata de político
cortar mamata do judiciário
fazer reformas
que vão ser impopulares
que vão fazer sobrar dinheiro
e aí a gente investe
na infraestrutura
então nós ouvimos
vários especialistas
consultamos também
o Observatório do Clima
verificamos o seu
plano de governo
o Observatório do Clima
é uma entidade
de referência no assunto
e na avaliação deles
o programa
ele não informa
quais são as regiões
mais vulneráveis
que medidas adotar
para proteger
essas populações
e também
quanto deveria ser investido
porque
eu volto a repetir
os planos
já existem
nos governos estaduais
e municipais
eu vou repetir
os planos já existem
existe um problema
de dinheiro
mas o senhor
se eleito presidente
da república
qual o papel
do governo federal
na proteção
das populações
em relação
a essas tragédias
dois
dois papéis
o primeiro
fazer sobrar dinheiro
para investimento
em infraestrutura
o governo
não tem dinheiro
até vi ponte
caindo no Maranhão
o governo
não tem dinheiro
para infraestrutura
com nada
as coisas no Brasil
estão colapsando
por isso é importante
apontar prioridades
mas essa é tão prioritária
quanto uma estrada
no Maranhão
para ligar uma produção
de soja
até o porto de destino
tudo é prioritário
em infraestrutura
porque o Brasil
pode até ter um apagão
e onde é que o senhor
vai buscar esse dinheiro
como eu repeti
aqui para a Renata
nós precisamos fazer
reformas que vão
economizar nos próximos
cinco anos
1.1 trilhão
com essas reformas
vai começar a sobrar
dinheiro
e os juros
vai baixar
juros baixando mais
licença e aumento
ambiental que passou
investimento
investimento vai significar
emprego
aumento da competitividade
e aí atender
esses problemas
que são dramáticos
e um outro tema
que é central
que envolve vidas humanas
o nosso plano nacional
de desfavelização
desfavelizar o Brasil
é salvar as populações
mais pobres
quase todos os grandes
desastres terminam
atingindo pessoas
que moram em regiões
de encosta
e regiões favelizadas
um país que não se desfaveliza
é um país que aceita
que as pessoas mais pobres
são tratadas como animais
eu vou desfavelizar o Brasil
e vai vir através
desses cortes
os cortes que eu estou propondo
são para muita gente
impopulares e dolorosos
quero ver o Lula
falar disso aqui amanhã
gostaria de ver o Flávio
falar disso
eu falo
candidato
chegou o momento
das suas considerações finais
por favor
meus queridos amigos
nós chegamos até aqui
construindo uma campanha
que conversou com o Brasil inteiro
eu rodeio o Brasil mais pobre
eu rodeio o Brasil
com o maior número
de dificuldades
eu amo o nosso país
e eu sei que o nosso país
nasceu para ser
uma das maiores nações do mundo
gostaria de construir um Brasil
que vai declarar
guerra ao crime organizado
que vai permitir que você
ande na rua de maneira segura
que eu sei se você é mãe
você sabe que a sua filha
corre risco
ninguém se sente seguro
a andar numa grande cidade brasileira
eu vou permitir que as favelas
do Brasil se tornem bairros
e que as pessoas que moram lá
se tornem cidadãos
eu vou olhar para o Nordeste
eu vou desenvolver o Nordeste
o Nordeste vai ter um futuro glorioso
ele vai ser a nova locomotiva brasileira
eu vou transformar esse país
num canteiro de obras gigantesco
que vai fazer com que a nossa produtividade
aumente como nunca antes
eu vou fazer com que você
não mais sonhe em se mudar
do Brasil para outro lugar
eu vou fazer com que o Brasil
o Brasil das novas gerações
o Brasil dos mais jovens
seja o país que a gente se orgulhe
não por conta dos campeonatos de futebol
música ou coisa que valha
mas sim por ser uma das maiores nações do mundo
vamos sonhar esse sonho
tem dois projetos de poder
do Lula e do Flávio Bolsonaro
que não valem nada
estão cansados
e eles rifaram o nosso futuro
vamos acreditar que o futuro seja glorioso
acredite em mudar o seu destino
eu estou aqui dando minha vida por isso
eu espero que você
cumpre também essa ideia
muito obrigado a todos
muito obrigado Renato
muito obrigado pela entrevista candidato
obrigada
amanhã o nosso entrevistado
é o candidato Luiz Inácio Lula da Silva
do PT
uma boa noite para você
e até amanhã
boa noite
muito obrigado
e até amanhã
e atam